there's some super interesting new
polling that i want to talk about about
the 2024 election and specifically about
what republicans are thinking and the
bottom line is donald trump's support is
rapidly collapsing among republicans who
ultimately will decide is donald trump
the 2024 republican nominee or is it
going to be someone else now
we have seen already in january two
pretty sizable rallies and every
indication that donald trump is going to
continue doing more of them in march
he'll be speaking at the
republican national committee meeting
some kind of mini convention or event in
new orleans louisiana this is a guy who
wants to be involved in 2022 and he
wants to use 2022 as a way to ultimately
have the option to be the nominee in
2024 if he so chooses up until now we've
basically been saying
the 2024 nomination is trump's for the
taking if he wants it
it's now a question mark and we're gonna
look at some recent data which shows at
least some republicans seem to be
getting sick of the guy and this is a
very very different situation when one
where it's trump's if he wants it uh the
associated press reporting trump facing
legal and political headwinds as he eyes
a comeback and it references that video
we showed you last week where trump
referred to himself on the golf course
as the 45th and 47th president sort of
alluding to a 2024 run
and the article points out his
popularity among republicans is
declining somewhat with 71 percent
saying they have a favorable opinion of
trump compared to 78 in september but
the new poll shows only a narrow
majority of republicans 56 percent want
him to run for president in 2024 the
poll found 44 percent do not want him to
run
this is a very different situation to
what we had throughout most of 2021
particularly the first part of the year
56 to 44
among republicans
want him to run that's basically 50 50.
now of course that's still fine for
winning the primary in the sense that if
56 of republicans support trump and the
other 44 percent support a bunch of
other people some ron desantis some
whoever right mitt romney jeb bush trump
still wins with that but these are
dramatically lower numbers than we
previously had another interesting
article in the washington post do
republicans love donald trump as they
once did which writes his support within
the party
may not be quite as robust as it once
was
and that is based on a lot of the same
polling this one though references a
washington post university of maryland
survey completed at the end of last year
found that more than six in ten
republicans say
there is evidence of widespread voter
fraud nearly six and ten say biden's
election was not legitimate more
republicans say they want trump to run
again in 2024
than they say want another candidate but
the margins as we talked about
50 uh down to 54 to 46
and then lastly there is a marquette
university poll just looking at
favorable versus unfavorable on trump
and if you look now
uh
you see that
trump's favorability
is down to only 32
67
now have an unfavorable opinion of
donald trump only 32 percent have a
favorable opinion of trump so there is
going to be a real question here as to
whether this guy is actually viable this
is great news now i don't want to praise
republicans for this i saw some
commentaries online saying republicans
are finally coming to their senses no
they're not
uh republicans are much the same as
donald trump or it's what have i heard
about recently and because donald trump
has been sort of out of the public
spotlight for some period of time i
think this is mostly an artifact of that
if there's no real
uh alternative appealing alternative to
trump
i think it's completely reasonable and
even likely uh that donald trump will be
back before you know it and and popular
but there's a very interesting kind of
uh intermediate period here where if
trump's role in the 22 midterms is
seeing more as a nuisance
rather than an advantage and if some
trumpist candidates lose in 22 which is
just nine months from now at this point
and some new republicans not at all
connected to trump win
it may just move the republican party
into saying i don't know i think we're
just kind of beyond trump there's
nothing moral here where the republicans
have said we cannot allow this again
that was really bad it was bad for the
country it was bad for the world it was
embarrassing this is not about that this
is just a sort of what have you done for
me lately top of mind type thing and i
think some republicans are just kind of
like oh yeah trump that guy
uh i don't really know that i want him
to run again and as we saw um even from
the people we talked to at the trump
rally in conroe texas over the weekend
it's not that these are reasonable
republicans it's that they just seem to
be thinking maybe it's time for somebody
else so we're going to keep watching
these numbers really closely but this is
a significant shift away from trump at
least in recent polling
it is a brand new year maybe you have
goals around getting in better shape
maybe cutting back on sugar
that's why you should check out our long
time sponsor magic spoon magic spoon
tastes exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 14
grams of protein and only four net carbs
so it's perfect if you're doing low carb
or keto or if like me you just try to
limit your sugar intake you can build
your own variety pack with flavors like
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite magic spoon
lets you enjoy a sweet delicious snack
without the guilt you can stick to your
goals and still treat yourself and if
you don't love magic spoon as much as i
do they'll give you all of your money
back no questions asked magic spoon is
giving my audience five dollars off when
you go to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman